Let's say I had the reaction
where I had some copper ions.
They have a positive
charge of 2.
It's an aqueous solution.
There could be some
other negative
ions in that solution.
Actually we could talk about
that in a little bit.
But we know that when you have
these ions in solution, they
all disassociate.
So you just have to know you
have a bunch of ions just
floating around in water.
There could be some other
negative ones to neutralize
the entire solution, but let's
just worry about the positive
ones for now.
And in that solution, I'm going
to put a bar of zinc.
And what happens is that they
essentially switch places.
The copper wants to jump out
of your aqueous solution.
I should probably draw this.
Let me draw it.
This is my solution.
And in my solution, we make it
blue, because it's aqueous, so
most of it is water.
I have some copper molecules
here in the solution.
They're a plus-2 charge.
I could have some other ions
that are negative, like some
nitrate ions or whatever, but
they're all disassociated.
They're all mixing around with
the water molecules that are
polar, and that's why ions
disassociate, or salts in
general, disassociate
well in water.
And I stick a bar
of zinc in it.
Solid zinc. So let me do that.
So I stick of bar of
solid zinc into it.
And so what this reaction says
is that these copper ions, if
they can get a hold of some
electrons and essentially
become neutral, they would
rather go back
into the solid state.
And the molecules of zinc out
here that are in the solid
state, if they can lose some
electrons, they want to jump
into the solution.
So let me write down
the whole reaction.
So if the copper can get some
electrons, they're going to go
into the solid state.
Copper will go into
the solid state.
And if the zinc can lose some
electrons, they'll become
positive ions or cations.
And then they will go into the
solution, plus-- I'll do the
same color-- zinc plus
2 plus aqueous.
Actually just so, a little
side note here, these are
actual ions.
We've been dealing with
oxidation numbers.
And when you want to know the
oxidation number of an ion,
the oxidation number is the
same thing as its charge,
because it's no longer
hypothetical.
Remember oxidation numbers were
hypothetical charges if a
bond were ionic.
In this case they are ionic, so
the oxidation state, or the
oxidation number is the
same as the charge.
And just as a side note, the
convention, if it's written 2
plus, this means that this
is a real charge.
If it's written plus 2-- at
least this is the way I
learned, and maybe there's
different conventions in
different places-- then it would
be an oxidation state,
which says, oh, it's not
necessarily an ion, but this
is what it would be
if it was an ion.
So if someone writes plus 2,
this is oxidation state.
If they write 2 plus,
they say, hey
this is a real charge.
And likewise, if you just have
a regular ion that has, like,
a charge of 1-- so let's say you
have Na plus-- this means
that it's an actual charge.
If you wanted to write its
oxidation state, you would
write plus 1.
Small little note, it doesn't
probably make a big difference
in the whole scheme of things,
but sometimes it can get
confusing whether something is
an oxidation state or an ion.
But depending on where you're
going to school and what your
teachers or conventions are, you
might want to clarify that
and just make sure that they use
the same conventions that
at least I remember when
I first learned it.
So anyway, let's go back
to this reaction
that's happening here.
So let's do the half
reactions for this.
So we start here, and actually
we can just look at the
oxidation states
to begin with.
This guy has an oxidation.
He has a charge of 2, which is
also an oxidation number of 2.
And he goes to a
neutral charge.
So clearly, he gains two
electrons, which means that he
was reduced.
He went from a positive
charge to a zero
oxidation state or charge.
So his charge was reduced.
Just let me write that.
So this guy was reduced.
And let me write his
half reaction.
He essentially started off
with some copper in the
aqueous state, and he
got two electrons.
That's how you get reduced.
So plus two electrons.
And he ended up in the solid
state of copper.
And his oxidation
number is now 0.
Now let's see what happened to
the zinc. The zinc, it starts
completely neutral in
the solid state.
No extra electrons or deficiency
of electrons.
But then once the zinc jumps
into the solution
here, he has a charge.
So he must have lost
electrons.
So the half reaction for zinc--
in this situation you
have zinc as a solid and he
reacts to produce two
electrons and he's in the water
and he's now an ion.
So let me put that there.
An aqueous solution.
So if we did this experiment
right here-- and I will tell
you right now this reaction
moves forward.
This is truly a reaction.
We're going to talk about, in
a second, how badly do the
electrons essentially want to
jump from-- where are they
jumping from?
They're jumping from the
zinc to the copper.
So we're going to talk a little
bit about how strongly
they want to jump
in the voltage.
And voltage is really just how
badly does charge want to move
or how much potential energy
does charge have. But this
whole reaction, you just have
to think about what's
happening, is that you have
charge moving from-- as the
zinc jumps into the water, as
the zinc jumps into the
aqueous solution, it's passing
on some charge to the copper
that jumps into the
solid form.
So electrons are moving here.
And if somehow we could
harness these moving
electrons, we could
create a current.
In this situation, it's
all chemical.
The electrons are moving around,
but they're not doing
it in any organized way.
Because the solution
is all mixed up.
But this is an interesting
situation we're
dealing with here.
And we can even talk about how
badly the electrons want to
move in these directions.
You can look at these
half reactions.
You can look it up in a table,
and you can get these energies
or the voltage is for
these reactions.
And this half reaction right
here has a voltage.
So they'll sometimes right E.
Sometimes it's an E not right
over there, but that's like
kind of out of the scope
of at least a
first-year chemistry course.
But they'll say it's
0.34 volts.
And then this reaction in this
direction has a potential
difference.
The energy is 0.76 volts.
If I wrote this in the other
way, if I wrote this reaction
of zinc plus 2 electrons going
to zinc solid, then you would
just switch the sign.
But what this says is that this
state, this state right
here, is a higher energy
than that state.
So it wants to go in
that direction.
And it wants to do that with
an energy per coulomb.
And you can watch the
physics playlist on
more details of volts.
But volt units are joules
per coulomb.
This is how badly the electrons
want to join the copper.
That's the best way
of viewing it.
And this is a measure of how
badly the electrons want to
leave the zinc. So if you wanted
to talk about this
whole reaction, so this whole
reaction that we have up here,
we could say it's an energy, so
the energy of this entire
reaction up here.
We know that electrons really
want to join the copper with
this energy, and they really
want to leave the zinc with
this energy.
So the energy of this entire
reaction, how badly do
electrons want to move from zinc
to copper to form this
over there, is just the
sum of the two.
So you get what's 1.1 volts.
You're probably saying, hey Sal,
all this talk of volts,
this is interesting
and current.
Is there some way that we could
construct a battery or a
galvanic cell?
If you don't know what a
galvanic cell is, it's what
we're about to construct
right now.
And the answer is obviously yes,
because that's the whole
point of this video.
So how can we somehow
harness that charge?
So let's separate the
two reactions.
Let's separate the two.
So let me put my
zinc bar here.
I'll try to stay true to the
colors that I used earlier.
And let me put my copper
bar there.
Actually maybe I should
copy and paste
what I wrote up here.
Just so we remember the
reaction itself.
Actually, yeah let me do that.
Never hurts.
OK.
I'll paste it down here.
Ignore all the squiggly
lines around it.
And let me put but both of my
bars in some aqueous solution.
And there could be some other
dissolved ions in there to
help neutralize the different--
so I put them both
in an aqueous solution.
But they're separate.
And let me label them
appropriately.
So this is my zinc. Zinc right
here, a bar of solid sync.
And this is my bar
of solid copper.
I should do that in
a different color.
So this is copper right here.
My bar of solid copper.
And then I have an
aqueous solution.
So what happens if we
were to connect
these two metals, right?
They're metals.
If you look at the periodic
table they're
both transition metals.
They both have the
sea of electrons.
So they both conduct
electricity well.
What happens if you connect
these two with a wire?
So if I connect them with a
wire right here like that.
So we already know that the
zinc is just dying to jump
into the water and lose
its electrons, right?
So let's say that happens.
So the zinc jumps into the
aqueous solution, and it turns
into a positive ion of zinc.
And then its electrons are
left behind, right?
So it essentially has
two electrons.
I did the half reaction
right here, right?
The zinc jumps into the solution
and it leaves behind
two electrons right here.
Two electrons here, they really
want to jump off of the
zinc.
Now I have a lot of copper out
of here, out here in the
solution, that really want to
jump on to this bar of copper.
But right now they're
all ions.
These are all plus 2 ions.
And they really want to jump on
to the bar and join all of
these other copper ions here.
But in order to jump
on to that, they
have to get some electrons.
Each of these guys have
to grab two electrons.
And we know that kind
of potential, or the
electromotive force with which
they want to grab those
electrons is 0.34 volts.
These guys want to jump here
and grab electrons from
someplace with plus
0.34 volts.
These guys want to jump off
of the bar and leave their
electrons behind with
0.76 volts.
So what do you think's going
to happen if we have a
conducting wire here?
Well those electrons are, once
this zinc just jumps off,
those electrons are going to
travel through the wire.
And then they're going to be
available, because these are
surplus electrons, to merge with
these copper ions that
want to jump back
on to the bar.
So these copper ions are going
to jump back on to the bar.
But from this reaction
what's happening?
You're having a current flow.
Current is actually flowing.
And what is the voltage
across this?
How badly does an electron want
to go from the zinc on
this bar to over here, join
with some copper in the
solution and let that copper
join on to that bar?
It wants to do it with
plus 1.1 volts.
Now the question is the
electrons are flowing in that
way, what is the cathode
and what is the anode?
So the cathode is the positive
terminal of, well, you can
already imagine, this is a
battery of sorts, right?
Because we are able to generate
a current by having a
voltage difference across
two terminals.
The cathode is the positive
terminal.
That's where the electrons
want to go to.
And then the anode-- and you can
familiarize yourself with,
you know, just a cation is a
positive ion and anion is a
negative ion.
So the anode is a negative
terminal.
So what's the negative
terminal here?
The negative terminal is where
the electrons come from.
See, electrons are coming from
the zinc jumping off.
So is your negative terminal.
And what's the positive
terminal?
That's where the electrons
want to go to.
They want to go down here and be
available for these coppers
that want to jump out
of the solution.
So this is our positive
terminal, or our cathode.
This is the cathode.
This is the anode.
And if someone says, hey, does
oxidation or reduction occur
at the cathode or the anode?
Well what's occurring
right here?
We have zinc in its solid
state right here.
We have solid zinc jumping in--
and it's neutral-- and it
jumps into the solution and it
leaves two electrons behind.
So it's losing electrons.
When you lose electrons
you're being oxidized.
So this is where the oxidation
is occurring.
Likewise, on this side you
have copper ions that are
already in the solution, and
they're gaining electrons.
So their charge is
being reduced.
So the cathode is where
reduction is taking place.
Reduction.
Now you're probably saying, oh
Sal, this is a nice cute
little, you know, battery-- or
this is called a galvanic
cell-- that, you know, you've
created this current.
But I see a problem here.
Because as this happens, you're
going to have more and
more positive zinc ions jump
into the solution here.
You have more and more positive
zinc ions in here as
this progresses.
And you're going to have fewer
and fewer copper ions in here.
So if you assume that there
were some other, let's say
there was, I mean, maybe to keep
the solution neutral--
the copper is positive-- maybe
you had some chloride in
there, chloride anions
that were keeping
this solution neutral.
And maybe you had some chlorine
anions here that were
keeping, well, it started
negative but then it maybe
gets a little bit more neutral
as the zinc jumps in.
But once this happens a
lot then it becomes
very positive, right?
This is becoming more and more
positive as more and
more zinc jumps in.
And this is becoming more and
more negative as more copper
jumps on to this bar.
So what can we do to
solve that problem?
What they do is-- and this is
just one way to solve the
problem, there's actually many
but this probably what you
might encounter in your
first-year chemistry class--
is they create something
called a salt bridge.
And what they do is they create
a, I guess we could
call it a pseudo-aqueous
solution of salt.
Maybe it's potassium chloride.
So in here we have potassium.
Potassium has a plus charge.
It's aqueous, plus
chlorine with a
negative charge aqueous.
And I say pseudo-aqueous
because it's not really
super-liquid water.
What they do is they try to
make it more viscous so it
just doesn't mix completely.
If this was pure water, then all
of it would just fall into
the solution, and you would
really have nothing up here.
It would be a useless device.
But what they do is they create
a gel that's still
aqueous enough that the
ions can move around.
The sodium and chloride
So let's say that those are
the-- sorry, not the sodium,
the potassium-- let's say
that's the potassium.
And let's say the chlorine ions
are-- I already did it in
that blue-- so chlorine
are the minus.
And what happens is as we have
this oxidation reduction
reaction that's causing these
electrons to travel from the
anode to the cathode, this
becomes positives, this
becomes negative.
The salt bridge allows the
negative components of the
ionized salt and just waste the
chlorine to go into the
solution to neutralize it.
So they'll end up having more
and more chlorine as
the zinc pops off.
If you were to evaporate the
solution you'd end up with a
bunch of zinc chloride.
And on this side, to keep the
balance here, you'll have a
lot of the positive parts,
components, of the salt.
So the sodium would jump in to
replace the copper that's
jumping out.
So when you have this whole
thing it enables the current
to keep flowing without having
a bad effect on the charge.
Because, you know, what
happens if this
becomes really positive?
If this becomes really
positive-- I'll do it in
vibrant color because there's no
salt bridge-- at some point
the electrons are going to say,
hey, I can either go over
here and drive this reaction
or, hey, I got a lot of
positive stuff hanging
out here.
Maybe I don't want
to leave it all.
So you have to do something to
neutralize the charge here.
Likewise, if this becomes really
negative from all the
chlorine atoms jumping out,
electrons aren't going to want
to go here.
Because like charges
repel each other.
So that's what having the salt
bridge neutralizing the
solution does for you.
It keeps it from getting
negative, and then our
galvanic cell can
keep operating.